Tammi écoute je t'aime bien et je ne
veux pas qu'on se batte comme on l'a fait
ces derniers mois
je ne sais pas teddy je veux dire quelqu'un
doit changer tu sais parce que je ne peux plus faire
ça
c'est trop  beaucoup non je sais je sais et et
c'est pourquoi je veux avoir un bébé tu fais
ouais un bébé vraiment ouais je pense que si nous
avons un enfant à aimer ça nous apprendra à nous
aimer à nouveau oh mon dieu Teddy
tu ferais mieux de ne pas  joue avec moi je
jure devant Dieu de ne pas jouer avec toi je
pense que tu ferais une maman géniale oh mon
dieu tu te moques de moi
nous avons tellement aimé ça assam Amin alors qu'est
ce que tu dis nous tous bon bébé je t'aime
aussi